it's just wholesome as all hell and i i
just needed that
[Music]
really knowing is good not knowing or
refusing to know is bad
or amoral at least you can't act if you
don't know
acting without knowing takes you right
off the cliff there's something
purely magical about this book i've
always loved ray bradbury i think i was
drawn mostly to his
personality and i read you know some of
his short stories in fahrenheit 451 and
stuff like that but i was just so drawn
to this personality that was so full of
love
and excitement and creativity and he
spoke about
living life in a way that was just so
full of idealism i guess
i really needed a good bradbury
story and i'm very happy that i read
something wicked this way comes because
at its core it's just a poem of love
i mean i don't really know any other way
to put it it is written with love
it is about just loving being alive and
and the
the joys and the fears and the
excitement and the thrill of
growing up so what is this book even
about and why
does it make me feel so emotionally
connected to it it's about
these two kids i think they're 13 years
old 12
will halloway and jim nightshade you
can't really just give
a basic description of something wicked
this way comes because the magic of it
is in the writing it's in the writing
style it's in the way
bradbury exudes the sensory
detail it's overwhelming it is just pure
it's poetry but it doesn't it doesn't
move into just
self-indulgence it really has a momentum
to it it moves
the sound the smells you just feel so
incredibly immersed in this book in a
way that you aren't immersed
in um you know a lot of stuff so back to
the story of will and jim
get caught up in a mysterious how shall
we call it
a traveling carnival they come in the
middle of the night there are two
people who run this business mr cougar
and mr dark
mr dark is the illustrated man he
has tattoos all over his body and those
tattoos can do
some very freaky stuff and in fact
there's a lot of freaky stuff in the
book it's like
stephen king before stephen king except
even more
sentimental in some ways very just like
childhood
creepy vibes you know it just this book
just gives me feelings of
just being young and the fears of
growing up and the
desire to grow up that's a big part
because there's an attraction at this
carnival that is able to make you older
or younger
and mr dark is a fantastic creepy
villain
this book just like um just knocked the
soot out of my head
as bradbury would probably say give me a
shake knock this
knock the soot off my chimney because
living
we accumulate so much knowledge in
ourselves we kick ourselves inside
with improper knowledge at times and
what we want to do at times is just bang
our head
we know so much that's not true yeah
yeah that's right see things fresh
like a kid would see it that includes
all of the fear
all the excitement the joy the joy this
book
for being you know a creepy spooky book
is incredibly
sentimental and incredibly when you read
a bradbury story
you're coming in knowing you've got
you're going to be getting his
philosophy about life very optimistic
idealistic attitude this book is
optimistic about human beings and about
good and evil
it's just wholesome as all hell and i
i just needed that i think the reason i
hadn't read this
already when i i could have read it for
many years and wanted to
it just seemed like i was holding off
something i knew would
warm my soul in a a way that i needed it
to every fall i go will i read this
while i read this but this fall i did
and i'm
so so happy i did there are some scenes
and chapters in this book that are just
people talking about good and evil age
what it means to live a good life i i
can't recommend this enough
of course if you don't like flowery
kind of writing although it's not overly
flowery like
it it's also concise that's what i love
about bradberry's writing it's concise
and to the point but also
very metaphorical if you're not into
that you may not enjoy it the themes
cohere
the story comes to just a great ending
every october i feel like i'm just going
to want to reread this those are the
kinds of books that i love
and cherish and i want to return to
always sometimes the world just kind of
packs your brain in with stupidity and
nonsense and then
you read something that's just emotional
and i'm
extremely grateful for for bradbury as a
writer thank you for watching as usual
like and subscribe if you're into that
sort of thing